the magnitude of the blast area
is the first thing that strikes you as
you survey this fractured landscape
mile upon mile of devastation it just
goes on
on ground level and across the city
everyone is shell-shocked
and they're all asking the same
questions why
and who is to blame as hekmat kai begins
to clear up outside his bakery
he's also trying to make sense of
something else far more profound
i've been through the war and tough
circumstances but i never saw something
like this before
thank god our damages are only material
but i'm wondering
how cheap a human being is in this
country where are we going
beirut was completely destroyed in an
instant
the explosion is something none here
will forget
bride isra seblani was posing for her
wedding photos
when the explosion ripped through the
streets around her
24 hours later and she returned to the
same spot with her husband
safe but shaken by the experience
feel so sad about what happened to other
people
about what happened to lebanon when i
when i woke up and i saw the damage that
happened to beirut
i realized the one thing i said was
alhamdulillah we're still alive
anger is growing the former prime
minister saeed hariri's convoy
was attacked by protesters he and his
family
are amongst the elites blamed for the
corruption which many here say
is at the heart of all of the country's
problems
with the city plunged into darkness the
security forces
are now taking control of these broken
streets
the government's declared a two-week
state of emergency
the authorities are now saying that more
than half the city has been damaged by
the blast now
countless families are having to spend
another night outside in the sweltering
heat this area is normally an area of
protest and there is a great deal of
anger here
but for the moment they're gathering to
bring in humanitarian aid
which they're hoping to distribute in
the coming hours
hayat nazir is gathering bedding it's
basic
but better than nothing she blames the
government for this catastrophe
i have one one concern that if other
countries are going to help
lebanon and if they're going to give the
money to the government then it's like
they're giving money
to those who destroyed us and killed us
they will steal the money
lebanon is now a country with crisis
piled upon crisis economic collapse
political meltdown
covert 19. and now this the smoking
crater of the port
asphyxiating a city which is already
drowning
in debt and corruption